is there any element of that character
that you wouldn't have been able to
access
had it not been for this styling format
yeah i think um we haven't really seen
um her her
like like some like this like kind of
silliness there's some the thing that
i've loved most about this show as an
actor
was getting to put this character you
know trust the writing put this
character
through a comedy have her you know play
the part as best as she can
what we know of her life and the mcu
world comes knocking
there are these moments of tension
that we give the audience and to play
with those
levels was was what was like so
fun for me so getting to kind of
play with her as like this mama bear of
like
trying to hold on to to something and
just the the tension of it um
with something that you know is one of
the elements that i
that i enjoyed but there's there's so
much tension that
um that shows itself
through these episodes that reveal
little bits of what our show is about
and those are
um those were like my my gems
[Applause]